we're in position
you
hey youtubers is Charlie we finally got
Black Panther vs. Winter Soldier so
let's break it down there's really a
whole bunch of other stuff going on in
this clip too like Iron Man with his
special watch attachment to his suit
it's kind of like a more compact version
of the suit like the briefcase suit from
Iron Man to just something that he can
wear piecemeal if he wants to and we got
a new suit at the end of Avengers age of
Ultron but remember he has a lot of
different suits to suit different needs
ha ha Tony Stark rim shot but the oh
[ __ ] look on his face here as the Winter
Soldier tries to shoot him Point Blank
is priceless it's like he pooped his
pants just a little bit then you have
him running the gauntlet of Avengers so
Winter Soldier is on a tear here Winter
Soldier vs Iron Man then Winter Soldier
for just agent 13 then vs. Black Widow
then vs. black panther so you got a
bunch of Avengers trying to take him
down Mike Tyson's punch-out style
I'm really happy agent 13 get some more
badass scenes in this like we didn't see
her much in Winter Soldier and she was
wearing that awkward pantsuit for most
of it well it's like yeah she was a
badass but that didn't really come
across in the movie now you really get
to see it and if you missed it Black
Widow is punching him in the nuts right
here as hard as she can and she's
actually pretty freaking strong you can
see his reaction face here like oh [ __ ]
that's gonna leave a mark and he's
almost like Captain America without the
Super Soldier Serum so he's still a
badass so he just he rolls into the
black panther fight whatever's going on
with him in this movie a big part of it
is him trying to regain his memories
from his time as Bucky before he became
Winter Soldier because it almost looks
like he's in the state of hallucination
as he's choking her out but we got to
talk about the black panther fight here
this really looks like black panther
round one then he comes back for him
later in the movie in the black panther
suit and gives him the business during
the airport fight like yeah you may have
won round 1 but round 2 is gonna be mine
it's kind of hard to tell what kind of
fighting style they gave him for this
movie I'm guessing it's a blend of
African martial arts and capoeira
because it does look like capoeira but
he's from Africa capoeira is a Brazilian
martial art which is from South America
so it's a completely different country
so what I'm guessing is is they just
combined a few different styles to
create something that's totally new
because the Dora mill J honor guard from
the comics they have their own special
martial art too and I can't remember
what the name of it is but it's
something unique to what
so it's not like a real-life martial art
you just meant to be like an extra
deadly version of real-life martial arts
so they'll probably suss that out more
during the Black Panther solo film you
get a much better sense for their
culture in that movie we're really just
getting a preview of Wakanda and civil
war and you may have missed it
but look at the bullet that he's wearing
around his neck that feels like it's
really important like maybe that's the
bullet that killed his father maybe
that's a bullet that almost killed him
I'm guessing this film is gonna touch on
his family history and they are casting
his father for the Black Panther solo
film but I don't know if he's gonna be a
ghost in that film or if he's still
gonna be alive because we did get a bit
of a ulysses klaw teaser during Avengers
age of Ultron when he said he paid a
very high price for the vibranium that
he acquired they might explain that
during the Black Panther film but he's
one of Black Panthers biggest enemies
but here's my big question for you guys
what do you think that that bullet
around his neck means and if you've seen
the movie please don't put any spoilers
in the comments they've been doing a
couple early screenings but I'm not
going to be seeing it till the first day
that it comes out so no worries I'm not
gonna be doing any Easter Egg videos or
spoilery reviews till after it comes out
but they did finally reveal what Baron
Zemo looks like in the film they did
confirm that Daniel Bruhl is playing
Baron Zemo this is what he looks like
very real-world so based on his
description they say that he tries to
track down the Winter Soldier to find
out about a hit that he may have
performed in the early 90s I'm wondering
if Winter Soldier killed the first Baron
Zemo and he's gonna be like Baron Zemo
son and he will take the title because
Baron Zemo in the comics is a title that
gets passed down from father to son
there's even a Baroness emo so I'm
wondering if Baron Zemo is gonna be like
an evil version of black panther father
gets killed son takes the mantle it
seems like everybody in this movie has a
diametric opposite like Captain America
Iron Man two sides of the same coin
Hawkeye Black Widow you know you get the
idea but we still got a couple weeks ago
they started to talk about some of the
other films we'll probably get some more
Doctor Strange footage in the next
couple weeks so be sure to subscribe to
get all that stuff if there's any Marvel
bonus videos that you guys want me to do
just let me know in the comments there's
been a whole bunch of big WTF news this
weekend so white guys wait for me to
post my next video you can click here to
learn all about Deadpool - Spidey pool
they've been talking about spider-man
crossover but it's very tongue-in-cheek
and you can click here to watch the
Doctor Strange teaser thank you
much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight